your range of motion doesn't have to
change because you age you're going to
be less powerful you may be able to
maintain your aerobic power for a long
time we know that that to be true but
your ability to express your range of
motion in your joints doesn't have to
degrade necessarily you may have bony
blocks and a patina of athleticism
right but we're as we take the systems
approach you being able to get up and
down off the ground or flex your knee
all the way doesn't have to go away one
of the things we know is that pain
doesn't mean injury it doesn't even mean
tissue trauma damage it's a request for
change so part of what we're trying to
say in this book is hey we can try to
treat pain and use it just as another
metric and so if we can shift that
narrative a little bit and then also
Empower people that hey there's a whole
lot they can do and some of that is
sleep and some of that is nutrition but
all a lot of it is there's some inputs
you can do that are really safe and
really easy